what's going on welcome to part 14 of
our intermediate Python series and part
2 of the object oriented programming
miniseries within that series in this
tutorial what we're going to be doing is
just taking this you know class and
actually in putting it into an
environment basically so we're going to
code the environment part here and and
then we'll be able to get back into
actual object-oriented programming so
really this is even probably most mostly
a PI game tutorial just utilizing this
blob class anyway let's hop to it
so we're going to import PI game at this
point you will need PI game and sold and
we're going to import random because we
are using random here and we need to
make sure we're going to be able to do
that now we're gonna have a bunch of
constants we're going to have width
that's going to be 800 we're gonna have
height that's going to be 600 and then
we're gonna have some colors these are
just tuples of colors they are RGB and
ìfree they're additive I guess I'm
trying to think of the proper word
someone can comment below the proper
word may be additive is it anyway think
of it as light so our GB we've got full
red light full green light and full blue
light that creates white light when you
have all of the lights if you had no
lights 0 0 0 that would be black anyway
we're going to give glue as you might
guess blue would be 0 red 0 green but
full blue and then we'll have one more
for now and that's going to be red and
red will be full red 0 green 0 blue cool
so those are our colors now we're going
to define the game display this is for
high game and this will be PI game
display dot set mode and set mode takes
a tuple of your wit and your height PI
game to split us up good now what we're
going to say is PI game dot display dot
set cat chin not really necessary but
we're going to call this
the world and then we're going to
specify the clock so we can kind of
handle frames per second as best as
possible okay so we're done with kind of
the initial setup now we're going to
come below this class and I'm just going
to make some space so I can scroll up
generally pepp eight suggest one line of
white space between functions and two
between classes so we'll define draw
environment here environments for now
we'll just leave it empty
and we're going to say game display dot
fill white so what's happening here is
for every frame you have to redraw
whatever you want to that frame and this
is our way of clearing the frame so
it'll have a white background and we'll
draw on top of that white background so
we're drawing or we're filling with
white and then we would in theory draw
on top of it for now we're not going to
do anything and then we're going to run
PI game dot display dot update and that
actually updates to your screen so when
it comes to computer graphics it's not
necessarily the most processing
intensive are the most kind of time
intensive or whatever to to bring
graphics to screens but it is a it is a
challenging process nonetheless and so
generally what you'll do is you'll
actually in the background like when we
say game displayed out fill out white or
game display fill white the user if they
slowed the the game down enough right or
watched it in slow-mo it's not like the
background first is going to go all
white and then little objects are going
to be updated to the screen that's not
how it's going to work what PI game's
going to do is truly in the backend it's
going to okay it's going to say okay
we're filling with Y and then it says
okay maybe we're going to draw an object
which we will so maybe we've got a blob
here it's going to draw a blob there and
then when it's all said and done it's
going to say okay this is the final
final result that we actually want to be
the new frame and then it sends it to
the screen that time for real and this
is sending it to the screen this is in
the background waiting for us to
basically call this so pygame dot
display to update cool and then we're
also going to actually we'll leave that
empty for now
one space or one line between
unfunctional main function this is just
going to contain the main part of our
program so first we're going to do what
we can define well first we'll define
the blob here in a moment first let's
just let's make the environment so while
true whereas a four event in PI game dot
event dot get this just grabs all the
events from PI games events and we're
going to say if the vent dot type is
equal to PI game dot quit so if it's a
PI game quit event this is basically if
they click the X in the top right corner
or top left panel for what operating
system I suppose anyway if that happens
we're going to say PI game dot quit and
then we're actually going to also quit
stop the program otherwise still under
the well truth not so many over then
what we're going to do is draw
environment so basically if it's not a
quit event this will draw environment
and then we will clock not tick 60 and
this is to hopefully if we can process
quickly enough we will get 60 frames per
second but we will not second but we
will not will not go over 60 frames per
second this this is our way of capping
the frames per second because our gain
the actual speed in which things happen
in our game we're not working with a
physics engine or anything like that so
it's going to be entirely contingent on
the frames per second themselves so game
designers are probably like the horror
but anyways that's how we're going to do
it so uh we're to save that and now
we're going to finally end with our if
name equals don't forget your string
their main what do we want to do we want
to remain okay let's run it and see if
that works
I'm expecting some sort of typo
something is going to be like Harrison
you're dumb well I'm expecting something
at least nothing's happening I'm
pressing run there we go oh okay great
we actually got what we wanted
surprising okay so as we can see it's
just a
white screen because that's all that's
happening but our environment so far is
acting the way we would hope that's good
so we'll close that and now let's
actually get the blob to interact in
this environment so first what we can do
is we need to create the object so we're
gonna say red blob equals it's going to
be a blob object and if you recall blob
object does take 1 basically when you
initialize this because the dunder init
method has an argument here for color
when you actually create the object you
must pass a cup pass a color but you
could say like color equals red and
actually have a default right just like
default parameters and functions we're
not going to but you could so at least
not right now eventually we'll talk
about why you might want to do that but
for now we're not going to do that but
blob and we're going to say that color
will be red that's really all we need to
do just just as a quick aside as far as
like Pepe Aaden stuff is concerned
luckily this line is short enough and it
like makes total sense red blob equals a
blob when we see the words red it's
relatively easy to take from this that
chances are we're creating a red blob
you know that's pretty simple but as
time goes on in this in this this class
gets much larger and maybe there's a lot
more arguments eventually it gets to the
point where the things that you're
seeing it doesn't make sense it's not
logical just reading this you don't you
almost have to like go back to the the
class and read it from it and so a lot
of times it does make sense to say like
color equals red but in this case
actually it would be like this but in
this case it's not necessary but
eventually we will hit a time when we've
got a lot of parameters and we're
exceeding 79 characters but I'm still
going to suggest that you do this in
times where it might be ambiguous or not
informative what that parameter or
argument is anyway red blob we're
passing or we're not doing anything
we've just created the object but now in
draw environment let's go ahead and pass
red blob to draw environment and then in
the draw environment function let's say
yeah let's take a blob so that's going
to take the blob object and then after
we filled the game display as white
we're going to come down here and we're
going to say pygame draw dot circle
where are we going to draw the circle
we're going to draw it to the game
display what color is a circle well it's
blob dot color whatever that happens to
be what is the location of the blob
that's blob that X blob dot Y and then
what is the size basically the radius of
the circle blob dot size so maybe these
pixels and rate its radius not diameter
but radius and pixels I'm just
referencing this four to eight I think
that's what it is anyway make sure that
this line occurs after the fill white if
you have it before fill white it will
literally it will draw the circle and
that will paint white all over it and
that would not be good so make sure
that's coming second so now barring
typos or logic errors we should get a
red blob on the screen sure enough we do
it's hard to see on this screen but I
think you can see it it's right here
awesome and you should be seeing that on
your screen now how might we get this to
be a little more animated
well basically anywhere in the draw
environment function we could just
simply call lob dot move so this is an
important thing to take into
consideration that when we pass this
blob object and blob up move empty
parameter or empty parentheses let's run
that really quick okay now your little
blob should be kind of wiggling around
now one thing to note is that is
modifying the actual blob itself red
blob fromm blob dot move is being moved
so if we were to come down here in print
let's just print the X&Y so red blob dot
X and red blob dot Y so those will just
print out to console
you can see they're actually being moved
the original object is being modified
through this name so this name is on
point this bit is still modifying that
object and later on you'll see that you
can pass even more many objects at one
time and they still do get get modified
so I think it's a good spot for us to
stop we still have a lot to cover
obviously with object oriented and like
I said this tutorial is more of getting
the pygame kind of environment set up
and kind of working with that object so
anyways if you have any questions
comments concerns up to this point if
you're having any problems with pygame
or whatever feel free to leave them
below otherwise I'll see you in the next
tutorial